well how about uh we take a look at
what's going on over in afghanistan we
have the story it's pretty interesting
tucker carlson questions if biden admin
botched afghanistan withdrawal on
purpose and we got some more stories to
potentially back up the claim that joe
biden screwed up afghanistan on purpose
tucker carlson pondered whether or not
the administration deliberately botched
the afghan withdrawal during his show
thursday evening
carlson's guest glenn greenwald was
discussing how there are elements in the
political establishment that would like
us to remain in afghanistan the
conversation led to the host questioning
if there was a possibility there was an
interest in screwing up to justify
future engagement quote i never want to
be a conspiracy not at all but i mean
everything you said is true so far so is
it worth at least wondering this is such
an obvious screw-up
you you and i have no experience running
a military or logistics withdrawal i
can't even organize my garage but even
you and i would probably do a better job
of withdrawing than these guys
it was just like it was comically bad is
it possible that an interest in making
it bad to justify future engagement or
is that too much to even speculate about
well i give you the story from the daily
mail glenn beck claims u.s state
department and biden's white house are
blocking his efforts to rescue afghan
christians from the taliban who want to
set them on fire
why
would they tell someone with the the
capability of of helping in the
evacuation
not to why would they block that
unless
they want the chaos
so they can justify remaining well i'm
going to give i think there's there's
some legitimate reasons and some
illegitimate reasons i mean the
illegitimate reason they they don't want
to be shown up yeah they know our troops
are not allowed to have not been allowed
to leave the airport area to go rescue
americans elsewhere in kabul much less
the rest of afghanistan but you know if
you flip it around if you're trying not
to have a confrontation with the taliban
and trying to get everybody out and
you've got random elements out there who
let's just say are more cowboy-esque and
willing to fight if they've got to well
then government's gonna then then the
taliban's gonna see that as as
engagement across the board and then our
troops are fighting so i i can see that
but what i can't see is when the state
department rejects would you get people
to the airport the state department says
sorry you can't come in
now that
their our state department is not
requiring all the paperwork for
everybody gets there that they're
getting out so then you look it more it
looks more like hey you showed us up you
made us look bad let me make a better
point
the morning of the attacks
the u.s and the uk warned their citizens
to stay away
the
marines who lost their lives were also
briefed
that there was potentially going to be
an attack
they were still told to process afghan
allies
something doesn't add up here
think about this in full context you've
got marines at the at the gates checking
ids for afghan allies to bring them in
the u.s says someone is going to try to
attack us american citizens stay away
but we'll still board afghan allies so
they tell the americans no you're not
you're you can't come right now because
it's a threat
these people are welcome to get on the
plane and many of them did they're not
they weren't worth as much
but something doesn't make sense this is
this
this to me is well beyond a mistake for
all i know the u.s government could have
planted the freaking bombs and lied
about it it's dude we're in conspiracy
world what the heck's going on
conspiracy world we're talking about a
fact that they issued a warning saying
americans stay away they told the
americans not to come and then told the
marines to keep processing the afghan
citizens and then a bomb went off
killing marines and afghan citizens and
the reason why there weren't americans
there is because they were told not to
be there but 13 americans died u.s
marines who are still down there
checking ids at the airport why weren't
they pulled from from the from the
checkpoints why didn't they say if we
can't get americans out we ain't getting
anybody out and we're not going to risk
the lives of our troops no they said
stay at your post the someone's going to
attack us we won't let those americans
die but you your cannon fodder that's
just what they did there it is i can't
imagine that it was an accident no
immediately after it happened you get
biden come out and say we're gonna go
after whoever did this at a time of our
choosing at a place of basically saying
just so you all know this is a green
light for us to reinvent or to re-attack
we're gonna hunt them today
so you also remember they're also
talking about blowing up all the
vehicles and
and aircraft that we left so you know
you talk about oh ongoing relations with
the taliban but by the way hey you know
those jets are flying over your country
blowing up your stuff you know they're
ours yeah you know i
and when we've
we made it clear we're not getting
everybody out you know we we know we're
not getting everybody out so then
what happens the first time because the
taliban is not a top-down organization
it's not you know it it's not like the
us military where when the president
gives an order you expect a private
somewhere seven thousand miles away to
do exactly what the president ordered so
let's say the first time taliban
not just chops off the head of an
american but
live cast it somewhere you know it
spreads the video on the internet
what are we gonna do about it i mean
that's this is gonna be an ongoing thing
how many hundreds or thousands of
americans and then also american allies
and are going to be left there
and you know it's
so i mean whether you like it or not
it's certainly been botched you're right
we could have done we could have gotten
the dnd group from downstairs we could
have planned a better exit
using you know using miniatures
and uh i just want to uh
stress this point that needs to be said
because it it it needs to be questioned
in a he there needs to be a hearing this
needs to be brought up
if they said
there is an imminent attack and
americans should stay away
but then told the marines to keep
working to process non-citizens for
transport something doesn't make sense i
think they were taking a risk like they
knew there was a probable attack but you
can't shut down just based on enough to
not evacuate american citizens enough to
say we will leave americans behind enemy
lines
something doesn't make sense if what is
joe but look
we're we're we're hearing wild estimates
some say a thousand to two thousand
americans still in afghanistan some say
thirty five to fifty thousand who knows
yeah that's some people i don't know if
that's true or not nbc reported fifteen
thousand then there was ap reporting
four thousand four hundred evacuated so
let's say maybe ten thousand we don't
know and when the biden administration's
asked they won't say
so we don't know
but it was enough to say americans
should not come for evacuation but not
enough to say
marines should should stop processing
you know i mean you could argue that
they're trying to clear the the crowd
around you know around the area so we
can get americans out but the problem is
the crowd doesn't dissipate it's
millions of people say as soon as as
soon as you clear out people who are
around the airport more people come
right because a whole bunch of people in
particular in kabul
want to get out you know if you're a
woman why i mean and you have some
opportunity to get out why would you
want to say in the you know 7th century
uh lunatic asylum where you're gonna be
sex slave and
you know that's just your entire future
you're not gonna be able to you're not
gonna be out of the burqa you're not
gonna be able to educate you're not
gonna be able to educate your kids
the kids will be taken and basically put
into military training why would you
want to stay so i understand why people
want to get out but
yeah
it's
it's like they they they said well we've
planned out every eventuality clearly
they did not that's a lie unless they
did and this is what they want
because i mean take it to its logical
conclusion if they if they did plan
every contingency oh wow so this is on
purpose well so why do we have to feel
this why did we close bagram air base i
mean that's really the big question you
you don't have to say we would take the
whole
you know exit plan to ba to bond from
but why do we close the base that's
isolated and safe and you don't have
really high buildings around where
snipers could you know shoot at you and
stuff like that
um something's wrong
this this is
you know part of me wants to believe
that biden fell asleep during a meeting
and kamala and millie and the other you
know uh members of his administration
were just kind of like uh so early lunch
and then got up and walked out like we
don't care that's on him not us he's the
one who's gonna you know be be uh
attacked in the media who's gonna blame
us huh
well it turns out a lot of people yeah
and i mean not just bucks stops with
biden and he's getting the most the heat
right but it's not just and to be fair
it's not just one party it's not just
one group of generals this is 20 years
of everybody owns this
and you know we've left
600 000 rifles
600 000 rifles in there thousands of
vehicles couple hundred aircraft we left
85 billion dollars worth of hardware
and i'm sorry i find it hard to believe
that
that's entirely accidental that
you're seeing idiocracy oh love
idiocracy uh mike judge man
oh yeah i just saw it a week ago yeah we
were watching it it's a documentary yeah
yeah yeah well so so you know i think
about how uh he you know mike judge took
this concept of like
if if nature just um rewards those who
reproduce the most what would happen and
i'm like let's let's let's take let's
let's uh
imagine a future
based on american foreign policy in the
middle east and what it leads to so
you've got you know isis
you've got the supporting of this of
syrian rebels and and arms dealing not
to mention fast and furious with the
cartels and you could make an idiocracy
where it's like after hundreds of years
of the us going into foreign countries
for intervention losing and then leaving
behind hundreds of millions of dollars
in supplies the world ends up with like
massive armed factions with like
american level technology in all these
different parts of the globe all going
to war and just blowing each other up
you end up with like
just 50 different isis isis a b c d e f
g h i j k l n o p and they're all in
different regions all with black hawks
and f-15s
bazookas and hundreds of thousands of
rifles be a good video game
yeah the year is 2130. america just
pulled out of its 87th attempt
here you go
like why did they decommission the
planes why didn't they melt them down
well they were broken we left all this
stuff for the afghan army i'm gonna i
have to lift my other arms as i can do
air quotes for afghan army i don't
really blame the afghan you know the
soldiers they lost 50 000 guys in 20
years fighting fighting against the
crazy taliban but their leaders were
corrupt their leaders were you know were
evil we weren't allowed to stop that uh
you know
the fact that it fell apart so fast
because they tried to create a modern
army for people who are not ready yeah
and kurt schlichter uh explained this
was saying that we built a modern
american style army with massive amounts
of logistics which is like the backbone
of any our army it was massive logistics
and then we removed the logistics from
the yeah when binding down when biden
pulled and said you know we're pulling
out he wouldn't allow the contractors
back in well the contractors were
maintaining the air force well they they
had a land-based army that was counting
on air you know air support and
and you know of course that they realize
hey you guys built the wrong army you
left us you left us out hanging out to
dry
we built
like some pentagon fantasy army you ever
played man and conquer yeah
they should they should have built tesla
coils just all over there's still time
this is this is really the og gaming
night this is
great we're whipping out command and
conquer matters
that aren't familiar with the reference
and command and conquer is like what's
like an isometric strategy game where
you build you collect resources tiberium
and then similar to starcraft yeah so
there's something you can build i think
tesla tessa coils are not right they're
like the bad yeah or is
so you build towers and they're tesla
coils and when anyone gets close it just
zaps them with a bolt of lightning and
just that was how i learned about the
word tesla i didn't know what i never
heard the name before that's how buried
that guy was we were talking about we
got weeds okay we got like weeds they're
growing everywhere and we used to have
this really nice like trim around the
porch of wood chips
and the weeds started growing and just
nobody really paid attention within like
a month it's just a jungle right
so i got a weed whacker but the weeds
are too overgrown and the whacker broke
so i was like what what do we do i'm
like we can take we have these throwing
axes i'm like what if we bolt the
throwing axe to the weed whacker
and then everyone's like that's a really
really bad idea yeah this is gonna eject
a hatchet you know if you're standing
next to it hold on and so i said what if
we took the magnetron out of a microwave
attached it to the end of a two by four
put a soup can on it direct the
microwaves and then carried one of those
high power batteries we have in our
backs and created a portable active
denial system and then we could point
that which would effectively boil the
water in the weeds and kill them
and then i realized whoa we can build a
portable active denial system that's
kind of crazy cool
active denial system is a microwave
weapon the military uses to make people
feel like they're on fire and i'm like
that's kind of crazy i'm sure your
neighbors would just love to know that
you built one of those we don't really
have neighbors i mean kind of you have
to walk quite a bit for the most part
but uh
i don't i don't know what the law is on
this i will just not do it i i think i
would recommend at least while we're on
youtube right now saying that you're not
planning on building this or we can plan
on hold on
you there's videos on youtube showing
you how to do it
yeah so when you put the soup can or i
think they might use a pringles can it's
like depending on the frequency of the
microwaves it focuses it
and so this is really cool they do these
experiments where they will take up two
by four put the magnetron on it plug it
in and they'll point it at fluorescent
lights and they'll light up
that's like it's crazy right like
wireless energy yeah and this is a
little a little maybe not off topic but
a bigger picture i can't wait what is on
time
state trying to like protect and control
the mind because it's this we have
access to the most dangerous and epic
equipment at all times we have open
flame for instance fire it's like yeah
you gotta you can get your own
flamethrower and it's the those
like for a human to experiment with
dangerous technologies part of how we've
developed and become what we are as a
species so to think that we could ever
mute that
for the safety of our our species is in
my opinion just is illogical thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you